[موسيقى]
ما عدا كل شيء هنا كما كان
وا يشبهوا هذا الطريق
كان ما ترك على حاله
المخيم الذي يؤدي اليه
تضيع تفاصيل الصوره
[موسيقى]
لا ترغب في ان يراها احد على هذا الحال
الدخول الى المخيم دونه الصعوبات كثيره
في هذا المخيم ينوء المهاجرون تحت ثقل
احوالهم
هذا مشربههم
وهذا المغسلهم
ما عدو ينتظرون شيئا من السلطات
[موسيقى]
بكثير من اعمالهم
نحو الف مهاجرين طروا للاقامه في هذا
المخيم في الجنوب الايطالي
عمر جاء من غينيا قبل سبع سنوات قبل ان
يصطدم باوروبا اخرى غير تلك التي تحلم
بالعيش فيها
هذه مثل افريقيا ليس هناك منازل مناسبه
ولا كهرباء ولاما انها فعلا افريقيا
[موسيقى]
على بعد 30 ساعات من المخيم تمضي الحياه
على طبيعتها في روما يتسالك ترون ما الذي
حدث حتى دخل البلد في نفق اللامبالاه
[تصفيق]
على هذا السؤال توجهنا الى هذا المطعم وسط
العاصمه الايطاليه
بتغيير مواقفه
استريم
متطرفا الضرائب ومرتفعه جدا والهجره كثيره
لا يمكن ان نستقبل جميع رؤساء العالم وهذا
ما دفعني الى التصويت لاقصى اليمين
الايطالي
[موسيقى]
استغلال ازمه الثقه واختارت شعاره حملتها
بدقه الله الوطن العائله
في ايطاليا لا تبدو معزوله تماما عن
سياقها الاوروبي ففي الجوار الفرنسي سيده
اخرى وتجربه مختلفه صحيح انها اخفقت في
الوصول الى السلطه لكن الواضحه انها نجحت
في كثير مما فشل فيه ابوها من قبل الى
هناك لنحكي تجربه التحول الكبير
[موسيقى]
هنا فرنسا بلد يعرف المهاجرين ويعرفون
لكن الجسور العلاقه بين الطرفين ليست
موصوله تماما
الفرنسيه ابحرت منذ عقود في رحله سياسيه
تطاردها اتهامه العنصريه
[موسيقى]
لم يمضي وقت قصير حتى تبين له ان التيار
لم يتغير وان غير جلده
[موسيقى]
غادرتهم لانه هناك عنصريه لا يمكن البقاء
في حزب يقول لي فيه بعض اعضائه عد الى
بلدك او يصفونني بالزنجي مثل الاخرين او
في حزب عدد من اعضائه فشيون
مثل هذه الشهادات يقولون انهم يعيشونها
واقعا
تتعدد التفاصيل في هذه المسيره الغاضبه
لكن عنوانها العريض ان الحان اقصى اليمين
لم تعد نشازا في المجتمع الفرنسيه
بغسيلكم
باي عقده نقص يخرجون ويتظاهرون ويعلنون
مواقفهم يجب ان نتذكر ان اكثر من ثلاثه
عشر مليون فرنزي سوتوا لازم ولبن
هم اذن اكثر من 13 مليون اقصى اليمين
والنتيجه ان هذا التيار طرق ثلاث مرات
ابوابا لزي مره على يد الابد ومرتين على
يد البنت
ما يحدث الان وهو مخيف هو ان فرنسا تخون
نفسها عندما تدير ظهرها لقيامها الاساسيه
ولم نعد في حاجه الى اقصى اليمين لفعل ذلك
لان الاحزاب الاخرى تقوم بالدور نفسه وهذا
مخيف جدا حتى ان اقصى اليمين اصبح حزبا
عاديه
برمتها يمينا حتى غدا من الصعب التمييز
احيانا بين اقصى اليمين وبين بقيه الاحزاب
فقط
تقدم النموذج لذلك
لطالما وصفت الدنمارك بانها بلد التعايش
وارض اللجوء
شعره العيش المشترك تصريف شوارع الدنمارك
وفضاءاتها لكن للصوره الاخر فالبلد الذي
اشتهر بها الوانه المتنوعه تم من يريد
صبغه بلون واحد
على بعد 30 كم من كوبنهاجن في غابه لا
يجاورها احد
وقيم هذا المخيم
يبدو اقرب الى سجن منه الى مركز ايواء
تمكن من الدخول اليه وهنا يتمدى حجم
الماساه
فالمقيمون فيه لا يمكن ترحيلهم لاسباب
امنيه او سياسيه
منذ اربع سنوات في هذا المركز مثل الاخرين
عليه فقط الانتظار دون افقي او امل
الدوله
كل هذا يحدث في ظل حكومه توصف بانها وسطيه
هكذا بدا ان معظم الطبقه السياسيه قد
امتدت صهوت افكار يقصى اليمين
ومقادير الطبخه السياسيه الدنماركيه
السعيره كلها من قاموس سياده سياره دونما
حاجه لركوبه قطار السلطه والامثله كثيره
[موسيقى]
من اصول مهاجره وذاك ما لا ترغب فيه
الحكومه فكان قرار وتفكيك الحي هو ترحيل
سكانه
لا تعرف فينا كيف يحدث هذا في بلدها
موقفها الغاضب يرى من شرفتها من بعيد
ولم يسبق لي ان احسست بغياب الامن العكس
هو الصحيح اشعر دائما بالدعم من قبل
السكان
مختلفه
[تصفيق]
في هذه المسيره الغاضبه تستعيد كوبنهاجن
تنوعها القديم تختلط الالوان والاعراف
لتمديد بقانون اعدته ويا لا المفارقه
حكومه الاشتراكين الديمقراطيين
من يضعوا قوانين اكثر عداء للاجانب ليس
لدينا حزب واحد في البرلمان يهدد بهذه
السياسه
ولم يعد احد يعرف علامه هذا المزاد اليمني
المتواصل في اوروبا هل يواصل صعوده ام
سنتهي مثل اي فقع
محمد البقالي الجزيره
[موسيقى]